but she was for the beheadings Oh media
outlets have simultaneously painted a
sympathetic picture of these terrorist
Brides now yearning for their homelands
so did they honestly want us to feel bad
for these women and one of the one we
just heard from Alabama native Hoda
Mathon a-- called for the quote spilling
of american blood and it's not just
happening here the UK struggling with
the same problem joining me now is Piers
Morgan editor at large for the Daily
Mail com co-host of good morning Britain
Piers
now you said of one of these brides
looking to come back to the UK that she
should rot in hell so tell us how you
really feel I just see her I see her
glib you know response to the question
about beheadings and I can't even
believe were like we're having to have
this conversation it's extraordinary
isn't it that we're even debating this I
mean this is a woman who goes over there
marries an Isis terrorist supports an
Isis terrorist breeds with an Isis
terrorist and his full intents and
purposes herself an Isis terrorist isn't
she I mean she's supporting the Isis
movement the Caliphate the desire to
take over the world with their barbarism
and she witnesses beheadings
and appears to think that's a good time
well I tell you what I don't agree that
that's a good time the headings are
despicable
medieval barbaric and everyone involved
in that kind of behavior has to be made
accountable and as we've just discovered
in Britain thank God
tonight the British Home Secretary the
equivalent of homeland security chief in
Britain has revoked her citizenship in
the case of the Isis wife who came from
Britain she won't be allowed back in the
country without a massive legal fight
and I hope America takes exactly the
same view of the American Isis wife who
by the way didn't marry one Isis
terrorists
she married three of them three Isis
terrorists so I'm sorry Laura but to me
this is completely and utterly nuts
there isn't anyone in America or Britain
new things I should come back yeah come
back and we spent all this money
litigating their case so some
court-appointed attorney who the
taxpayers have to pay for argue some
cockamamie idea about how she was like
patty
syndrome or something over there because
you know that's what they would argue
but us should revoke their citizenship
as well they shouldn't be able to come
back here you want to be taken care of
by the curves or situation over in the
Middle East where you're probably not
going to get you know the ACLU
representing you then that was your
decision piers I want to play another
little snippet from that Alabama Isis
bride and you will know you won't
believe it let's watch maybe
therapy lessons who maybe a process that
will ensure us that we'll never do this
again
so piers she's saying she perhaps could
reform herself through therapy lessons
invariably the American taxpayers will
have to pay for that - well let's be
very clear this is the same woman who on
social media three or four years ago
besieged every Muslim in America to rise
up and spill American blood and she
particularly wanted to do it using
trucks to spill American blood and in
fact two years later that's exactly what
somebody did in New York a radicalized
Islamist in New York got in a truck and
mowed down and killed a number of
innocent people
so she was crying out for this to happen
that blood was spilled now she wants to
think hey I'm sorry I know that the ISIS
dream in Syria is over I know that my
Isis terrorist husbands have now been
killed and I want to come home because
I'm now reformed character I'm not
buying any of it she was very severely
radicalized which is why she was out
there why she stayed out there while she
had these three Isis terrorist husbands
and I think she remains a very clear and
present danger to Americans and to
American lives now and kids they all
have kids they want the kids to come
back here go to American schools etc etc
appears I have to ask you you out in LA
about the Jesse Smollett hoax you
already get the sense that the
entertainment set has gone kind of quiet
for the most part so why are all these
Hollywood activists rushed in to condemn
this attack where are they like where's
Ellen Page I know who blamed but the
clearance where she yeah let's be clear
Laura they rushed in because for one
reason
this looked like the absolutely perfect
storm anti-trump story didn't it it was
a couple of guys a couple of white guys
wearing making America great caps who
had launched a deliberate and savage
attack on a gay black actor and had done
so because they were Pro Trump and that
was the whole narrative which dusty
smolla had told everybody he's been on
national television to reinforce this
he's given us a very clear account of
this appalling racist homophobic attack
the only problem is it looks like and I
hesitate to jump in with complete
certainty here because it's been a crazy
story changing almost by the hour but I
think most rational people looking at
the story now have come to the
conclusion it's a load of old hogwash
and this guy has probably invented the
story so if that is true it is hard to
imagine and despicable well where are
they I'll tell you where they are yeah
they want it they just want this they
want this to disappear they want this to
have never happened because the moment
it looked like it's it was now what
justice Mona told us how they came going
or let alone this is the worst thing
ever
now it's it never happened little Borna
that's that's how it always works when
the facts become inconvenient piers
thanks so much have fun out there on the
left coast